something i'm discovering recently is
this concept i'm calling it
modeling love
and uh simply put it's like your
positive actions as a parent show your
kids how to be good humans and that's
why we love dads who are doing just that
in our program that we started very
first on this show in season one good
dad program
that's right
and our next three guests are three dads
from memphis tennessee who made
headlines for their non-profit that
serves in their youth community and the
magic dads are making dreams come true
one book bag barbecue and barber shop
visit at a time please welcome diedrick
ford jason bobo and marvin boyd thank
you thank
you i'm so excited to meet you guys in
person oh yeah
yeah
dietrich tell us why the magic dads
organization was founded
yeah well we're all cousins and we
started the organization in our in our
neighborhood there's a lot of violence
and
drug and gang activity that traumatizes
our streets in our community
so we started out giving
haircuts
and this event grew
to the point where we wanted to
offer other things like giving away the
book bags and and giving away the school
supplies to help the community i work as
a
teacher's assistant for special needs
so i see hand in hand
every day the anxiety the depression
and the struggles that the kids deal
with
i also have a t-shirt printing company
where i do
what they call memorial t-shirts ripts
and there are kids that are barely 18
they have collections of these shirts
from their friends uh dying and being
killed on the streets
it's so disheartening yeah
oh okay
um marvin are the kids that you serve
and take care of like do you see that
they need role models absolutely i mean
we started this group just to let them
know that hey we're positive role models
and we do what we can for you and we
just want you to you know don't make
your life so hard life's already hard as
it is don't don't make your life so hard
doing things that you shouldn't be doing
jason what does the magic dad's
symbolize what's the intention tell us
about it okay well i also have a
barbershop called magic hands
so we started a smile with like events
in the barber shop and so for the
community and so all the kids will come
there so that's how we became quote
unquote the magic dads of the community
so then like our first event we used to
give haircuts and hairstyles for the
girls and boys going back to school for
their first day of school so that's how
we initially got into it and came did
you groom your own beard because it's
awesome i actually did it
that's one of the best beards i've ever
seen yeah thank you i was like you're
responsible i got to call that out
because i like i'm looking and i'm not
loving they always ask me what kind of
oars and things i'm using
marvin what do you tell yourself to
motivate
oh well
that's the thing i don't want to toot my
horn or anything but this will go ahead
it was my idea too
i got one of my cousins and i i just we
just see so much violence around i said
hey you know we're good guys and it's
something we need to do it's something
we need to tackle because
it's getting rough out there and we just
want to show the kids a positive role
model
um all right what's next uh jason for
the magic dads organization oh well we
actually hope that they can expand and
grow and just uh teach the kids
different things and
just be a better uh way of living in the
community as we train i love this and we
are so happy that you are always giving
back to the community so i thought it
was about time that you guys were on the
receiving end and we had custom magic
dad jackets made for each of you
so um if you don't mind we'd love for
you to throw those on if you're
interested thank you
oh wow
[Applause]
and they're cool they're letterman
jackets you know um and that's not all
our friends at state bags are also
providing you with 200 book bags to give
back to the children
[Applause]
and then there's one last thing
thank you so much thank you
with
this um five thousand dollar check just
to again enable
um you to keep doing what you're doing
and i'm gonna match this so it'll be ten
thousand dollars
[Music]
[Applause]
and don't forget to go to our website at
the drewberrymartian.com and see what
the magic dads are doing thank you for
doing what you're doing thank you
building the model
thank you so much thank you and let's
follow up okay i want to know what the
magic dads are up to all right thank you
dietrich ford jason bobo and marvin boyd
all the way from memphis tennessee and
we'll be right back
[Music]